your new show is called The Reluctant
traveler yeah and it's because you were
reluctant to even say yes to this
project right
yes because it's a travel show when it
was kind of pitched to me
and I knew I wasn't called The Reluctant
traveler when they pitched it to me it
was a travel show about
uh luxurious hotels around the world I
think it was called Room with a View
when it was pitched to me okay so I went
wow this would make somebody just go
through the roof with excitement
traveling the world and going to these
great hotels
but I'm not the person
for the show because you know I have a
very low sense of curiosity as a person
I have no sense of adventure
why am I telling the world this
but uh but that was the case I I'm just
not the person to front a travel show so
I said no uh there must be somebody
better to do this I don't think it's me
because I truly don't love traveling
that's disgusting and it could be
exhausting and you've got to be kind of
chit chatty and inquisitive which I'm
not really
so uh they found this amusing
amusing much the way you're laughing is
the way they were laughing on the on the
phone I just love this phone call when I
was saying no and giving them the
reasons and then they got together apple
and the producer of the show and said
wait a minute
that's the show
hotels countries traveling but with
somebody who doesn't like to do it
reluctant traveler and when that was
pitched to me I said I get it now I get
it I don't have to be somebody else you
know you know that's such a great lesson
though to still like be true to yourself
and do what you want to tell people like
no that's not me and and then it came
back to you exactly how it worked the
way it should be yeah somebody who
really doesn't you know care for listen
I've been in you know like going I've
been night hiking in the rain forest in
Costa Rica oh my God would I have ever
done that before I would
no why I'm dying to go to the rainforest
why because of all the creepy crawlies
because we live once and it's like it's
got to be beautiful right it is from a
plane
you know you all should have done you
should have found someone crazy like me
that was like love it
that's why I said no in the beginning I
wasn't the person for the for the job so
wait so when you go through your let's
say you're in the rainforest you get
there I mean you didn't enjoy it or
you're reluctant the whole time do you
think you get like bit by a spider or
something happen or I saw plenty this is
a night hike don't forget so we've got
flashlights and I was on either side of
this little walkway I'm just looking up
seeing a giant web with a thing
in it okay that's fine I was I was face
to face with an eyelash pit viper
what one of the most poisonous snakes in
the world wrapped around a tree branch
and I'm looking at this thing and and
thinking okay are they like Rattlers do
they just jump out at you
close oh to this thing and then the
guide says you might want to step back a
little bit because you're standing on
this ant hill these types of ants if
they ever bite you you'll feel it for 24
hours
now what I want to go through this again
is it something I would love to do again
no you would love to do it I would love
to do it you would like to do it
Barefoot probably
I will Tony Robbins out of that trail
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going
everybody